you say one of the things you live by is
be undeniable be undeniable which is
something you've always said
what do you mean by that i mean by being
undeniable in your talent your skill set
your craft
whatever it is that you do you got to be
you got to make people the
the secret sauce that i believe one of
the secret sauces to my success
is i just didn't go away same with you
right if you just stay
the course and you don't and you and you
continually hone in on your crap i feel
like you're gonna win
you don't have to be the best right like
what you just said about michael b
jordan right
if you undeniably are diligent or if
you're under like if did your girl [ __ ]
with you the first time she met you of
course not
that's what i'm talking about but you
are undeniably diligent and now you're
married
that's facts that's it be undeniable
bring value don't take your personal
other thing that you're big on is that
i'm big on as well is the entitlement
thing i hate entitlement
yeah it's crazy because especially in
this business now
man it's the worst these artists this is
something i remember talking to uh
i think just blaze was talking about
this on clubhouse one day
and how people have direct access to all
these people that you would never in
life have access to
and they just feel entitled to your time
or oh i'm gonna send you this record
right like what does that mean you're
gonna sit so when i tell artists like
don't be entitled it's like
you wouldn't walk up to a girl and just
say hey give me some [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying that's what you
say to a dj when you just walk up and be
like here's my song play it
right like you didn't try to like build
with me first like yeah that's how i
feel like that
that that's entitlement and that i hate
that [ __ ] that's like when people dm you
like man you ain't [ __ ] with me kev
like yo here like bro i don't even know
who the [ __ ] you are bro
yo you know yo the worst part is when
someone hits you with that in your dms
and they don't even follow you
like fam you don't even follow me yo you
don't even [ __ ] with me enough to follow
me and you're gonna hit me up trying to
get on my podcast to come to a freak
like who the [ __ ] are you
i remember somebody went on a campaign
i'm not gonna talk about who it is here
but if somebody in la went on a campaign
about how dj head don't [ __ ] with him
i don't remember him bro i don't
remember meeting this man ever
right so he went on a whole campaign and
was tweeting
dm in like the whole stories putting
stories up at me and everything i think
i saw that
and so i ended up hitting one of my big
homies and had me get in touch with him
directly and got on the phone with him
like yo bro what's the problem like i
don't remember you like this is how this
business actually works also not your
job to to know
everyone bro i don't know you that's
what i'm saying so it was just one of
them type of things where like
i can't do that kind of thing all the
time but i felt like i wanted to
i felt like it was a teachable moment
and in those moments i'll take the time
to educate